hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 le saluda raúl blanco esta vez
en reemplazo de mi compañero santiago
ariztía hoy nos acompaña de dar bronze
sociólogo francés y además presidente de
la misión de expertos llamada la
ilustración en la era digital un
proyecto que le fue encomendado por el
presidente de manuel macrón en 2019 esto
con el fin de evaluar o exponer los
desafíos sobre el impacto que tiene la
revolución digital en nuestra sociedad
los resultados de la investigación no
fueron presentados en 2021 con 30
recomendaciones para así disminuir las
noticias falsas y cómo evitar la
manipulación de los algoritmos
especialmente en procesos democráticos
señor varones gracias por acompañarnos
estar con nosotros en entrevista
quisiera empezar por ahí cuál es
entonces han sido los principales
hallazgos sobre la desinformación en
internet después de estos meses de
trabajo
y
se nos pidió que hiciéramos un estado
del arte de la cuestión porque hay una
ciencia que estudia los flujos de
información una ciencia pedagógica que
estudia cómo ser capaz de resistir por
así decirlo a las noticias falsas y a
las conclusiones a las que llegamos con
nuestro informe sugieren 30
recomendaciones no voy a detallar las
todas pero me gustaría señalar que el
informe gratuito y se puede descargar
fácilmente en internet pero a grandes
rasgos lo primero es que los
investigadores deben tener acceso a los
datos producidos por la llamada cafam es
decir facebook etcétera porque hasta
ahora la mayoría de las veces no
disponemos de esta información
en tiempos de pandemia la analogía les
parecería clara es difícil encontrar una
vacuna contra un virus si no tenemos
información sobre el virus así que eso
es lo primero
y los dos siempre
el segundo punto es que toda la
investigación muestra que lo que mejor
predice el hecho de que la noticia falsa
se va a difundir es lo que llamamos el
life thinking o pensamientos perezosos
es decir el pensamiento intuitivo cierto
preposiciones que nos da la credulidad
parecen verdaderas es lo factible pero
lo factible no siempre es verdadero en
todas las encuestas vemos que el hecho
de ceder a ideas que nos parecen ciertas
y que van en la dirección de lo que
queremos creer de nuestra ideología
político religiosa es lo que mejor
predice el hecho de ceder a todo tipo de
teorías conspirativas como por ejemplo
la antigua con acción y vías de escape a
medio siglo lucy cruzaban de unión a la
a sus objetivos y cumplo pasión para la
imaginación
lo esencial es fortalecer nuestro
sistema inmunológico intelectual es
decir desarrollar el pensamiento crítico
sobre todo en el caso de los jóvenes
pero no sólo con ellos también durante
la formación continua de los adultos
esto es un tema que debe convertirse en
una causa nacional y esta es una de las
principales recomendaciones de nuestro
informe un tercer elemento es que
sabemos que algunas personas son más
responsables que otras de discernir
información falsa consideramos por
ejemplo que el 33 por ciento del tráfico
en las redes sociales lo realiza el 1
por ciento de las personas los llamados
súper usuarios y aquí también proponemos
observaciones para intentar evitar el
daño que pueden causar estos super
usuarios y responsabilizarlos
decide un límite
fer67
o le responsabilizó claro y es que amas
a casi todo el mundo tiene un teléfono a
la mano y dice lo que quiere reenvía
esta información a través de los
mensajes a familiares amigos compañeros
de trabajo ellos los envían a su vez a
sus respectivos círculos y de esta forma
es realmente posible disminuir entonces
el flujo de noticias falsas que se
mueven en las redes sociales de
plataformas digitales y hasta qué punto
además
debido a internet la característica de
internet es proporcionar cantidades
masivas de información y cuanta más
información haya disponible más probable
es que uno encuentre información que
vaya en la dirección de lo que quiere
creer y eso es exactamente lo que
buscamos en general lo que llamamos el
sesgo de confirmación este sesgo nos
lleva a relacionarnos con personas que
piensan como nosotros ideológicamente
políticamente y religiosamente pero
cuando estas ideas son demasiados
radicales generalmente no las expresamos
en público las expresamos en grupos
privados que es el grupo privado de
facebook pero incluso más lo hacemos en
whatsapp o telegram por cierto hay un
buen estudio en francia que demuestra
que el hecho de haber participado en
grupos de telegram es lo que predice
fuertemente el hecho de creer en teorías
conspirativas o de tener un pensamiento
antivacunas es muy difícil regular este
tipo de cosas y por eso es problemática
la de plataformas acción cuando por
ejemplo se prohíbe una cuenta como
ocurrió con donald trump en twitter
existe la posibilidad de que estas
cuentas se refugien en otros grupos de
intercambio como whatsapp tele brahms y
muchos otros una vez más el último
recurso e insisto en ello es considerar
a estos individuos que han caído en un
tipo de creencia que puede ser peligrosa
en ciertos casos porque a veces inspiran
la violencia política no debemos olvidar
que son nuestros conciudadanos son seres
humanos como nosotros cometen errores
pero eso no significa que estén en el
campo del mal ser por lo tanto es
absolutamente necesario mantener un
diálogo con ellos porque tienen en sus
propias cabezas los recursos
intelectuales que quizás alejen estas
creencias pero cuando uno se adhiere a
una creencia es extremadamente difícil
volver atrás ese es el problema por eso
la cuestión de los radicalizados es
importante pero en primer lugar hay que
pensar en las condiciones para prevenir
esta radicalización asegurarse de que
los conciudadanos que aún no han oído
hablar de tal o cual teoría descabellada
no caigan en la línea de la credibilidad
hay que protegerlos de alguna manera y
creo que la mejor protección una vez más
es el desarrollo del pensamiento crítico
estamos seguros de que no es liberticida
pero no es la única protección también
hay que preguntarse como ciertas
noticias nada representativas y muy
minoritarias en la sociedad se hacen
extremadamente visibles porque las
portan súper usuarios que quieren hacer
valer sus ideologías y que consiguen
esos argumentos adquieren una
visibilidad que va mucho más allá de su
representatividad adquiere visibilidad y
tivat jesús de la del ojo preso está
chip y es que también hemos visto que el
mayor flujo de información suceden
cuando hay jornadas electorales o una
emergencia sanitaria como lo fue y luego
esta pandemia con 19 por qué pasa esto
lo pompón o la prodemi lukovic webs que
tras tantear eso no más que durante la
pandemia de kobe 19 es muy interesante
señalar que sobre todo en marzo de abril
se produjo un aumento del uso del mundo
digital es decir tanto de las
plataformas de vídeo como de las redes
sociales del 30 al 80 por ciento así que
es obvio que este este refugio en el
mundo digital porque estábamos
confinados y tenemos que mantenernos
ocupados
amplificó todos los problemas que ya
estábamos viendo en internet es decir
que la gente buscó más información en
las redes sociales o incluso más buscó
información que coincide
era en sus creencias es obvio que la
pandemia nos traumatizó a todos nadie
había experimentado esto una pandemia
global con confinamiento global pues
bien este tipo de situaciones inciertas
suelen requerir explicación y la ciencia
no siempre da explicaciones a tiempo a
veces hay que esperar por otro lado las
teorías conspirativas ofrecen
explicaciones inmediatas por ejemplo al
principio de la década del 2000 tomaba
alrededor de un mes que surgiera una
teoría conspirativa hoy sólo se tarda
una hora en que surja una teoría
conspirativa relacionada con un evento
andy de beijing y vemos que hay una
tremenda aceleración de la credulidad
también es obvio que los momentos
electorales son momentos bastante
idóneos porque todo el mundo se vuelve
hace un objetivo a polarizar los puntos
de vista nos empezamos a odiar pero el
problema es que ahora nos odiamos a los
2 o 3 días en las redes sociales en
francia hay más o menos una controversia
de cada dos días en subir en una
controversia colectiva que hemos entrado
en el mundo de la disputa de la
controversia permanente también hay que
decir que estos momentos electorales aún
también los momentos que eligen las
potencias extranjeras para venir a hacer
injerencia digital para tratar de
desestabilizar la democracia y esto no
es en absoluto paranoia mía está muy
bien documentado hay grandes potencias
extranjeras que conocemos muy bien hay
cuatro en particular que son muy
influyentes y que buscan desestabilizar
la democracia
ishares latixx de billy y dibujas ahora
ya que comenta este peligro de la
desinformación en las elecciones cree
que la democracia está en peligro en las
elecciones que vienen en américa latina
como colombia brasil costa rica y no
solo en la región también francia que
elegirá el presidente del próximo 10 de
abril está la democracia ha puesta a
prueba con la difusión de noticias
falsas
con el té
si esos ataques ya empezaron al menos en
francia la zona que más conozco o sea de
colombia espero que mis colegas me
cuenten más pero en francia estos
ataques ya comenzaron miremos por
ejemplo la guerra de ucrania hay un
estudio que demostró que hubo no sé
cuántos miles de cuentas falsas que
aparecieron en twitter el mismo día de
la invasión de ucrania así que es de
suponer que habrá algún control ruso
detrás como siempre lo supo esquiva
llevarás atún de color gris de ayax tú
sabes con david y
no creo que en francia el trolling de
estas potencias extranjeras pueda
cambiar el resultado electoral quizás me
equivoque pero no creo mucho que pase
sin embargo lo que sí puede cambiar en
la narrativa de los resultados
electorales los resultados de chubut con
disney para con status rise la nación
por ejemplo lo que podría imponerse es
que se diga que las elecciones estaban
manipuladas como hemos visto en estados
unidos donde algunos republicanos una
mayoría sigue creyendo que las últimas
elecciones presidenciales en eeuu fueron
manipuladas como lo entenderán si uno
cree esto ya no pertenece al mismo mundo
vive en la misma sociedad pero ya no es
del mismo mundo así que esto es lo que
podría afectar a las elecciones en
francia o en colombia o en cualquier
otro lugar no se trata tanto de la
modificación de los resultados como de
la modificación de las historias que se
comparan sobre estos resultados los
indicaciones de situar oaxaca appo pulse
resulta claro y es que precisamente en
relación a esto una de las primeras
medidas que tomó europa tras la invasión
a rusia y ucrania fue el bloqueo a las
señales de rt
sería la medida comprobable a las es
comparable la censura que ponen en que
imponen en rusia
no creo que la situación no es
comparable es efectivamente una censura
no digo lo contrario pero hay que saber
que estos medios rt sputnik han sido
señalados varias veces de delitos de
noticias falsas difusión de noticias
falsas y siempre al servicio de los
intereses de rusia por supuesto si esta
noticia es falsa y estuviera en el
servicio de diferentes estados cada vez
podríamos decir que se trata simplemente
de periodistas poco serios pero aquí
podemos considerar que se trata de un
organismo de propaganda y por lo tanto
no es absoluto comparable que en el
cierre de otros medios de comunicación
que ciertamente tienen posiciones
ideológicas por ejemplo cabe señalar que
en francia los medios de comunicación
siguen siendo libres tienen por así
decirlo diferentes puntos de vista hay
controversia hay medios de comunicación
de derecha de izquierda existe la
posibilidad de contradecir al gobierno
los medios de comunicación franceses no
se privan de ello y no creo que la
situación sea la misma con el señor
putin ahora ya por último para finalizar
nuestra conversación le quiero preguntar
cómo afecta esta medida al debate
público en europa en todo el continente
y creo que es algo que se podía haber
hecho hace mucho tiempo el pretexto de
la guerra de ucrania fue el detonante
pero la verdadera pregunta es por qué no
lo hicimos porque permitimos que los
medios de comunicación extranjeros
emiten noticias falsas orden
interpretaciones de las noticias que
sirven a intereses que no son los de la
nación donde se emiten y no son los
únicos por cierto es la nación
es un país hablando
de cómo hubo mucha controversia sobre el
jazz y era en su momento etcétera las
democracias son sistemas políticos de
libertad de expresión pero no deben
sufrir por su talón de aquiles es decir
la tolerancia a la intolerancia siempre
ha sido el talón de aquiles de la
democracia ligonnes aturdir y tanunda
childe de monjas gerald gracias por
estar con nosotros en este espacio
france24 llamado la entrevista muy
amable
y a ustedes también gracias por estar
con nosotros en un episodio más de la
entrevista autor mi compañero santiago
vestía hasta una próxima oportunidad
[Música]